I can't help but feel like if Harry
Potter was done by Disney that any
number of Disney characters especially
the princesses would just take over the
sorting song that was a lot of setup for
I'm what I'm not even sure qualified as
a punchline anyways hey there folks
it is time for me I would say it's
overdue for me to enjoy that little
exercise I said I like to do of sorting
characters who are not from the Harry
Potter franchise into the appropriate
Hogwarts house I've done it with some
Marvel characters with my partner Liz I
will get her back on this channel so
help me it will happen it's a schedule
thing mostly and I've done it with all
current incarnations of the doctor at
least all the ones we knew about before
series 12 happened hey but this one was
actually a request from a patreon
supporter to have me sort Disney
characters into Hogwarts houses now they
actually gave me a pretty long leash to
decide what characters I was going to do
and sort of the natural thing that will
come to my mind would be main characters
or maybe main characters and sidekicks
and there's obviously a lot to go with
it and we were talking about the
animated Disney properties however they
had a selection of specific area they
want to meet a sword not all of whom
were leads so that meant that I was
looking at a mix of leads and supporting
so what I ought to do was take the
characters that the Commissioner
definitely wanted me to do and then
picked another few characters from the
same movie that they appeared in and
that's how I'm getting the ones that I'm
doing so this is gonna come off a little
bit as kind of an eclectic mix of
characters but this is just how it broke
down and
so I'm gonna be taking a look and
sorting characters from five different
Disney films starting with because I
decided for no reason other than it just
seemed easier to go chronologically from
the oldest film up to the most current
let's start with Pinocchio
now we're gonna be taking a look at four
different characters from this film and
we might as well start with the lead
with Pinocchio himself Pinocchio was a
little bit hard to parse to be
completely honest because he is very
malleable he is very prone to outside
influence kind of the point of the film
is that he himself does not have a a
particularly fully formed persona and
personality yet he's figuring all that
out so in a way it might seem a bit like
a cheat to put him in Hufflepuff which
is where I'm gonna put him since that is
kind of the catch-all a lot of the times
for people who don't sort cleanly into
the other three but that really does
feel appropriate to him he's not clearly
defined enough at least over the course
of the film to really firmly fit into
any other of the three by the end like
maybe leaning a little Gryffindor but he
definitely dips his toes into Slytherin
along the way so I'm going with Hough oh
it felt like the best idea the best idea
I felt the most fitting for me now
relatedly Geppetto his creator also a
Hufflepuff
i I do feel he didn't really make any
sense putting him anywhere else so again
kind of landing there a little bit by
default which I don't like to treat
Hufflepuff as a catch-all but it really
is in many ways the hey you don't go in
those other three come here well welcome
you hang out by the kitchen it'll be
great so let's talk about a couple of
characters from Pinocchio who definitely
I can cleanly define how about uh-huh
Jiminy Cricket
that guy's a Gryffindor top to bottom no
question he is
Oh certain of himself I mean that's why
he has to be Pinocchio's conscience
because he has that level of confidence
that level of certainty and not a ton of
intellectual curiosity buddy right he's
right wrong is wrong and I'm gonna do
right yeah that's a very good friend or
attitude the other one is the character
who was actually specifically requested
and that is Honest John who I mean
being the con man that he attack on Fox
I guess that he is yeah yeah he's a
Slytherin
he's from my house I wish I could say
that he showed a little bit more
ambition he seems to be content to just
skim children but the man has such an
utter disregard for rules but not
because he thinks I'm doing the right
thing despite the rules he just doesn't
care and he's obviously doing all of it
completely for his own benefit not
looking at the impact on other people
not that all slytherins are like that
but it is a trap a lot of us can fall
into and he's falling into it hard next
up we're gonna talk about the Great
Mouse Detective now with Pinocchio I
started with the lead character this
time we're actually gonna work our way
up to the leads let's start with some
supporting characters and how about we
open with Dawson effectively the dr.
Watson to Basil's Sherlock Holmes Dawson
is a Hufflepuff he is he is here trying
to just ease himself back into his life
you know he has a sense of right wrong
certainly but he's not a crusader by
nature he knows what the right thing is
to do and he'll do his best to
accomplish it but he he doesn't have
enough of a forward thrust for me to put
him in Gryffindor which was the only
other place I was considering him Olivia
flowers him on the other hand oh she's a
Gryffindor Oh completely she knows
exactly what she thinks should be
happening she is not gonna stop until it
happens
stubborn as heck doesn't give up pretty
Curie
just a little kid - yeah she's a
Gryffindor so let's get to our leads cuz
you got to talk about basil and Ratigan
now basil was the character specifically
requested from this film now Ratigan as
is frequently the case with disney
villain he's is very much a Slytherin
the sheer scope his ambition the fact
that like not only does he think he
should be at the top because nobody else
deserves to be there his his sheer ego
and the relish he takes in clawing his
way up and getting and beating other
people whereas basil Basil's a ravenclaw
he's very into the deduction of it he's
very into the science of it he's very
into picking apart figuring out seeing
how it works not great at humor and
interactions just because that's not
where he puts his focus and it is part
of what makes him a really good clash
with rhadigan because all you know basil
does have kind of an ambitious streak
that normally goes a bit more slithering
but he his ambition is completely in the
realm of solving these things whereas
Ratigan's ambition is completely for the
sake of self glory and a man travels
next we're gonna take a look at Beauty
and the Beast we're gonna look at a few
more characters from this then we have
with the other ones this one was tough
some of these characters I am gonna burn
through some of them kind of quickly
let's actually start with our lead now
the natural inclination would be to make
Belle a ravenclaw because she reads a
lot and that's a trait normally
associated with Ravenclaw's but the
thing is it's not just that Ravenclaw's
read a lot it's why they read a lot and
Belle isn't really just trying to
accumulate knowledge to better
understand the world she is trying to
escape the world she
and that's why she reads so much she
reads so much so that she can experience
all the things out there that she
doesn't get to experience normally she
has a very firm idea of what she could
have that beyond this life that she has
she's very set in her ways she does not
budge when she knows what she wants
she's a Gryffindor the thing is this is
surprising number of Gryffindor's in
this film we'll get to some of the
others but first now bail may not be a
ravenclaw
Maurice her father definitely is just
total focus on the work the building can
I make this work tinker tinker tinker
tinker what uh my daughter's an adult
and like doesn't like living it oh sorry
tinker tinker tinker tinker you know is
just look at where his focuses dudes a
ravenclaw the other two supporting
characters I want to take a look at our
Cogsworth and Lumiere now Lumiere is
actually the character who was requested
that I place out of this so with him
he's a Slytherin he's such a schemer he
is always trying to figure out the ways
to get Belle in the beasted to meet each
other like it's he's the first one to go
it's a girl you know immediately
thinking how can we use this to break
the spell and start scheming start
planning they don't always work and he's
a decent guy by all means but like
definite schemer I put him in Slytherin
cogs wars on the other hand he is he's a
neurotic awful
he probably thinks he's a ravenclaw
because he's all like sort of he thinks
he's intellectually she just hadn't he
just has memorized a bunch of facts
though so that he can show off a bit
he's a bit of a chest puffer but he
doesn't have the actual intellectual
curiosity to work as a ravenclaw he's
not he's not firm and stubborn enough to
be a Gryffindor he tries to be but he
bends it doesn't work he doesn't have
the scheming nature and doesn't seem to
have the ambition you'd see of a
Slytherin so again kind of being the
catch-all I think he's a Hufflepuff
which also makes a lot of sense to me
because Slytherin and HuffPo friendships
are like some of the best things ever
so that makes
sense for me for Lumiere and Cogsworth
now that gets us to our other lead and
our villain I mentioned there's a lot of
Gryffindor's in this story I think
they're both Gryffindor's I think all
three leads our Gryffindor's which was
not my initial notion actually beast was
super hard for me to place easiest one I
had other three of them was Gaston
Gaston is a Gryffindor just what-what it
is specifically if we're gonna compare
the beast and guest on the beast I think
some people might think Slytherin
because you know he's selfish and all
this stuff but the thing is the beast is
a Gryffindor who's been humbled and
didn't and that experience didn't serve
him well but think about the traits kind
of inherent to him that come out over
time how brave he is you know just going
and taking on those wolves how much he
is prepared because it is the right
thing to do to put Belle's happiness
over his own like the the fact that he
let her go that is not a Slytherin move
at all so I do think he is a Gryffindor
so then to contrast him with Gaston who
where I say beast is a Gryffindor who
was humbled Gaston is a governor who has
never been humbled in his life he has
been at the top for probably as long as
he is known there was a top to be at and
he loves it there and he thinks the
world belongs to him now you again might
think Slytherin but the thing is he's
not actually ambitious he's just
comfortable and he's pigheaded and he's
darn certain that his view of the world
is the right one and he just feels very
blustering Gryffindor and thinking of
them in those terms I think it actually
makes them are really interesting
contrast you already have the inherent
contrast of the attractive person being
a monster and the monster being a decent
person but beyond that they feel like
they emphasize different sides of the
same kind of person that Gaston is in a
way what the Beast could have been if he
had not ever been brought low at some
earlier point in his life and as for
Belle like I said she's just so
pharmacist she's stubborn
she's just as stubborn as either of the
two of them and she is dang certain in
terms of the right and the wrong and the
where these things should go and for all
of her reading and everything else she
already is pretty set in her ways so I
think we actually have a trio of
Gryffindor's heading this film which is
interesting
next up The Nightmare Before Christmas
this is another one that was a little
bit tricky to suss out if I'm being
honest let's do some supporting
characters first the the the easiest one
that I placed from this film dr.
Finklestein ravenclaw again focus on the
work focus on the learning the
experimentation make it work make it
better and that's just where his
interests are so that was an easy pick I
also decided to place okie boogie
because like I said the natural
inclination is to assume villain
slithering he's not though there's a
word I've been using when talking about
slytherins up to this point in this
video and that is ambition Oggy is not
ambitious okie just wants to kick back
and have a good meal that sounds like a
Hufflepuff to me so that's where I'm
putting him so that brings us to Jack
and Sally Jack being the character who
the Commissioner requested these two
were a bit trickier for me to place
Sally I kinda end up putting in huffin
mainly by default honestly a lot of the
times I have a hard time sort of sussing
Sally out as a character she is the
definition of a supporting player she
supports Jack she doesn't feel like she
has a ton of defined characteristics on
her own and I don't want to feel like
I'm knocking huh philospher saying that
I'm not saying like you folks don't have
design if you did find characteristics
but again because huffily tends to serve
a little bit of a catch-all she doesn't
firmly lean in any of the other
direction she doesn't have the the
confidence and the the stubbornness or
arguably the courage of a Gryffindor
she's certainly not especially scheming
she schemes like a little bit but only
really just to get away from dr. dr.
Finklestein otherwise no not really and
she's definitely not doing the deep sort
of picking apart analytical dive you'd
expect out of a ravenclaw so I put her
and huffily now Jack I think we might
actually have an instance of a hero
character who's a Slytherin he's bored
and when he sees somebody else's holiday
what does he think I can do it better
I'm not sure there's a more inherently
Slytherin thought than seeing somebody
doing something that you know next to
nothing about and immediately thinking I
could do that better it's it's the
epitome of that arrogance ambitious
arrogance Jack's got that and that's why
he belongs in my house all right last
film we're going to talk about lilo and
stitch and we're gonna run through six
characters on this but I'll try and get
through them relatively quickly first up
dr. Jumba now scientists characters
again you tend to naturally think
ravenclaw and obviously he has an
interest in that sense but the ambition
he is into world dominate or universal
domination I suppose he he has that
going on that is his motivation behind
it I'm putting him in Slytherin I am
however gonna put Pleakley as a
ravenclaw he doesn't know nearly as much
as he thinks he knows but that is
definitely the angle by which he
approaches situations what do I know
about this what knowledge can I apply to
it felt very ravenclaw to me getting
through some of the other supporting
characters we have mr. bubbles who I'm
going to pay
as a Gryffindor he is he's a bit of a
hard-ass when it comes to the rules and
everything else and he's got a heart but
he's also like this is how it's got to
be because it's how it's supposed to be
so you know kind of a big papa bear of a
Gryffindor now we've got our three leads
Nani lilo and stitch and it thing was
stitch who was requested be like
actually remembers lilo says I think it
was stitch was there requested character
Nani I not he's another one I had a
really hard time placing and I landed on
huffin because she does have that she
has the selflessness that I think you
you get honestly more in huffily than in
most other houses because most other
houses there is some degree of pushing
forward the self whether it be through
you know courage and sort of moral
certainty that you get with Gryffindor's
whether is the pushing forward of the
attaining of one's personal knowledge
that you get with Ravenclaw's or whether
it's pushing forward the just wanting to
raise oneself up to greater and higher
heights that you get was leather and
puffles are more prone to self-sacrifice
especially for the sake of others not to
say the others aren't capable of it but
Nami has already sacrificed a lot and
even though it's stressing her the heck
out that does seem to feed into just how
she approaches life so I'm placing her
and huffing as for lilo and stitch they
lilo was not super hard once I actually
stopped and thought about it stitch was
a bit tough lilo is a Slytherin I mean
if you think about this kid and what and
you know you can chalk it up to age but
I can only judge her at the age that I
see her in the film and yeah she's kinda
into the idea of smashing
things up at least the fantasy of it she
understands right and wrong but within
that framework as she understands that
she's got ideas she's got plans she does
scheme so I'm putting a little o and
slither and asked for stitch
I think stitches a huffily a little bit
like Pinocchio from where we started to
bring it full circle it's almost like I
know what I'm doing
uh-huh he is very malleable and he's
very prone to influence the reason he
starts out as rough and slithering esque
as he does at the front end is because
he's under the influence of dr. jumba
now you might think well you just put
lilo in Slytherin so when he's with her
isn't she going to make him slow there
as well well no because she's not trying
to make him like her and she's not
trying to use him the way jumbo was
using him
so what lilo actually does his stitch of
presence is important to her because of
how having a friend helps her but she's
not using him as utilitarian Lee as
Jumba did and so lilo while she herself
is a Slytherin she exerts such a gentle
influence on to stitch that it allows
him to settle into who he's supposed to
be instead of force molding him into
what she wants him to be which is what
Jumba did so it allows him to find his
own path and his own path is let's all
hug it out and be family and have a good
meal and again that to me is very
helpful which is also very admirable
it's funny the more I engage in these
kinds of exercises I've really come to
appreciate hufflepuffs like know don't
get me wrong
proud of my house happy to be there I
belong there like let's not let's not
get ourselves but
I got a real soft spot for hopefuls uh
but there you go
five Disney films bunch of characters
from I'm sorted into their Hogwarts
houses I do enjoyed these kinds of
exercises so uh it's it's hard to make
time for stuff like this and basically
give me a kick in the pants by
commissioning me to do it that's one way
to get the job done and I'm happy to so
what do you think about the placement
for what I did what other Disney movies
would you like to see characters placed
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it you can support me on
patreon which is a massive help that's
how I was commissioned to do this beyond
that though like subscribe hit the bell
people have been saying they haven't
been getting notifications my videos
haven't been showing up with their
subscription feed lately they've had to
go to the channel hopefully if you hit
the bell that'll counteract that I don't
know but you don't have to do any of it
because end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meetings
and occasionally the sorting x' and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]